concernant l'autoroute effectivement de
nombreux martiniquais ont réalisé qu'ils
avaient des fissures longitudinale tout
le long de la route seront difficiles
tout à fait normal qu'ils sont liés à
l'utilisation et l'usure de ses
vêtements de dents au b2
de l'autoroute alors nous ça intervient
c'est ça fait partie d'un programme
d'entretien que nous avons sur nos voix
nous avons déjà repris l'enrobé de
l'autre sens de l'autoroute et
progressivement nous traitons toutes les
zones de façon à remettre à niveau les
la couche de roulement que ceux ci en
face d'eux
de cet automne sachant que la couche de
fondation de cette autoroute n'est pas
affectée n'avons pas observé de
déformation longitudinale ou
transversales particulière l'assiette de
l'autoroute a été stabilisé été gracié
depuis de très nombreuses années avec
des soutènements très très conséquent et
donc nous n'avons pas observé de
mouvement particulier sur tout tout le
trajet de l'auto ce sont des voix avec
un très haut niveau de service nous
avons environ 120 mille véhicules jour
qui passe c'est voir avec beaucoup de
poids lourds et donc ce faux départ très
sollicité et donc très surveillé nous
avons des programmes de maintenance très
régulier et donc nous programmons de
nombreux travaux pour maintenir ces
équipements un bon niveau de sécurité il
n'y a pas de lien entre les différentes
affaires
non il ya juste une concomitance
géographique puisque ça se trouve à côté
de la rue 9 mai les causes sont
totalement différentes
les porteurs d
des dégâts également